these former fighters used to plot
attacks on ISIL with an Iranian backed
group called aside I had an L hack or
league of the righteous now the more
than 1,500 men are soldiers in Brigade
43 of the Iraqi army al Jazeera was
given access to their training camp
about 85 kilometres north of Baghdad
Iraq is under enormous pressure by the
United States to rein in dozens of
paramilitary groups operating under the
umbrella popular mobilization forces or
PMF it was organized in 2014 to help
defeat ISIL the groups are primarily
Shia Muslim and many were said to be
funded by Iran then by July 31st Iraq's
Prime Minister Adel Abdel Mahdi has
given all paramilitary groups and
ultimatum operate as part of the Iraqi
military and cease political activity or
surrender their weapons and join a
political organization doing both will
become a violation of the Iraqi federal
law it's unclear if and how the new law
will be enforced the Prime Minister may
be addressed in a very specific group of
loyalists to Iran they believe there are
no geographic boundaries for their fight
that means whatever affects Iran affects
them whatever affects the Shia and
Lorraine Lebanon and Yemen affects them
this is the religious ideology rooted in
their minds and this cannot be
controlled by the prime minister the PMF
flag whips in the wind next to the Iraqi
1 brigade commander Rafat saleh ali says
their allegiance is to e rocks Prime
Minister but the commander spoke
repeatedly about resistance this was how
he responded when asked about links to
Iran
Josiah Shakur personally I thank all who
helped Iraq defeat ISIL and liberated
Iraqi lands during the time we were
fighting the American invaders I would
like to thank all who participated to
support the resistance foreign influence
in Iraq has expanded from the
battlefield to the Parliament during
last year's
parliamentary elections the second
largest number of seats was won by the
El Fattah alliance it's comprised
primarily of members of the popular
mobilization forces with the current
circumstances this new laws true intent
is to try to placate the United States
Natacha guy named Al Jazeera Belen Iraq